on va rejoindre tout de suite benoît
charette qui est le ministre de
l'environnement et de la lutte contre
les changements climatiques bonsoir ont
suffi lieu pourquoi vous vous limitez
aujourd'hui à une réduction de 12
millions de tonnes dans votre dans votre
plan alors que ça prend un plan pour 29
millions de tonnes
qu'est ce que l'on a présenté ce matin
c'est un port dans la bonne direction
donc on a aujourd hui les démarches
identiques 1 an 2 % des mesures à mettre
en place non seulement les mesures sont
identifiés mais nous savons de façon
bien précise quelles seront leurs effets
en matière de finition gaz à effet serre
et de socoa
nous avons le budget pour financer ces
mesures la plupart des plans numériques
et une à ma fille nous sommes
vraisemblablement les premiers
génériques sonore avoir un plan qui non
seulement les mesures les réductions et
les financements
donc c'est une avancée qui majeure et ce
qui le rend 2%
est ce que le reste il tenait son
quartier pour cent qui mentent financé
par l'achat de droits sur le marché
californie québec donc une façon cette
nouvelle aile parti de nulle part sans
fondement les réductions qui ont été
annoncés ce matin l'exercice de 42% se
fera à travers des efforts réalisés au
québec et des diminutions d'émissions au
québec que directement aux cris donc
c'est non seulement portable pour notre
environnement comme le précisait
certains pour cet électeur tout juste et
rare et c'est aussi extrêmement
profitable pour nos entreprises comme
laurent servière hier lors je vous parle
pas du 42 42% vous l'avez bien identifié
le 58 % manquants
est ce qu'il pourrait être comblé par
des achats sur le marché du carbone de
droits d'émission il n'en sommes pas là
du tout donc ceux qui me connaissent et
ça c'est pas non le 58 % manquants il
pourrait être financé ou combler cet
effort-là en achetant des droits
d'émission sur le marché du carbone
ce n'est pas du tout le but de la
politique été précisée est présenté ce
matin d'ailleurs
insiste sur l'évier fait des réductions
en sol québécois
le marché du carbone permet cette
éventualité là mais nous n'avons pas
parlé politique en fonction d'acheter
largement des crédits du côté de la
californie
on ne ferait qu'accentuer une balance
commerciale en notre défaveur donc le
but est d'améliorer le bilan carbone au
québec pour défavoriser les économies et
les entreprises québécoises mais oui de
marché du carbone le permet donc à votre
question est ce que c'est possible
les possibilités et là est-ce que c'est
notre intention
pas du tout on veut favoriser le
développement économique tout en
diminuant nous hissions gaz à effet
serre de façon pourquoi exclure
l'écofiscalité de votre plan il ya même
une commission de l'époque
l'écofiscalité au canada et en plusieurs
endroits dans le monde il ya du bonus
d'un côté il ya du malus de l'autre côté
quand on veut atteindre des objectifs on
utilise les deux outils pourquoi vous
excluez les cons fiscalité a fait on
utilise déjà vers 6 heures je vous
parlais de la bourse du carbone et
quelques descendants qu'elle attend
qu'il y à déjà le montant qui constitue
en quelque sorte une formule des quads
etc officialité ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui il n'est pas question
d'augmenter le fardeau fiscal pas
davantage les tarifs pour les québécois
et ça devient très très difficile
j'écoutais travers différentes entrevues
aux échanges aujourd'hui certains dire
que ce sera au gouvernement de
déterminer quel style de vie que d'une
seule ménages auraient besoin pour se
déplacer et en vertu de ce jugement de
valeur là on imposerait ou non un tarif
supplémentaires à l'échelle du véhicule
ce n'est pas du tout le rôle du
gouvernement que de tristes visite à les
besoins des consommateurs et nous avons
une formule actuellement fonctionnent
bien
50 % des véhicules électriques vendus au
canada sont achetés au québec dont nos
formules en est une de mobilisation et
on a un chemin afin que tout simplement
je viens vous l'avez dit quelques
instants mais pour attraper qui est
important donc le même temps voulait
susciter la mobilisation sont pas encore
à démobiliser des citoyens des citoyens
avec des frais supplémentaires
pourquoi des rabais sur des voitures
électriques
pourquoi ça c'est un jugement de valeur
correcte mais des taxes sur des voitures
polluantes par exemple pour décourager
pas pour payer la taxe ou le taré mais
pour décourager les gens d'investir et
d'acheter dans des véhicules dont la
croissance des ventes est quand même
exceptionnel depuis 1990 les camions là
en hausse de 2 163 % des ventes pourquoi
vous le faites pas ce pas là a fait on
un vaste territoire le québec n'est pas
que lundi lula le secteur centre-ville
de montréal donc des réalités au québec
qui amène les gens à préférer tel ou tel
ce petit véhicule donc on ne veut pas
s'immiscer dans ce choix là mais pour ce
qui est de notre décision de prolonger
par exemple le programme comores où
l'hiver ce qu'il a fait ses preuves et
le but programme dit oui de créer un
esthétique mais surtout de faire en
sorte que les subventions qu'ils
dépensent combiner les subventions
fédérales que nous souhaitons voir
renouveler fasse en sorte que le
consommateur
on n'est pas super d'opter pour un
véhicule électrique à un prix comparable
dont confié créer un mouvement monroe en
quelque sorte il vend seulement nos
ministres et ne nécessitera plus de
subventions afin d'entendre encore des
subventions tubes à demeurer
éternellement
premièrement on vise un certain
équilibre entre jeunes et neufs
électriques et les véhicules et
j'apprécie beaucoup
merci pour cette entreprise fut une
bonne journée